great to see you look beautiful come on
all right what a night The Producers
Guild Awards it's just another you know
step on the road to the biggest ending
of award season the Oscars and you are a
nominee how you congratulations I mean
so moved we're so honored to be here
tonight on behalf of marriage story so
it's very beautiful and and very moved
as well nominations and so grateful for
the support of both marriage story
literally I mean what does it mean to
you that at this point your career
you're still collecting all these
amazing amazing accolades and also being
a part of such a meaningful meaningful
work well I think most importantly to
feel not only proud that you get to
participate in films that you care
deeply about that move you that you feel
matter stories that you are so thrilled
that they are getting told in various
ways like that's what really matters and
then the fact that people connect to
them and they receive accolades and with
accolades as we know more people see
them and so it's you know it's much
appreciated especially in the world of
small independent film and so much
content that people get to find things
that you care about you have so many
amazing projects this year big little
lies a marriage story Little Women do
you feel extra excited to see anyone in
particular tonight or it's just a night
with all your friends well a night that
all three of those projects are being
honored here at the producer skills
that's really moving and all so deeply
with so much love produced by amazing
people I was gonna ask because look we
know you're a baby yota fan oh tyka is
gonna be here tonight and you know he
knows baby Yoda's real name and I'm just
wondering if you can get that out of him
oh do you Laura I think you know
something you're not telling us
she's gonna keep his secrets you seen
big little lies congratulations on your
Oscar nomination I mean what does it
mean to be recognized for your work in
the film but also to be part of two Best
Picture nominees amazing I mean two Best
Picture nominees that I made last year
with my friends who are also a couple so
I spent my year with them Noah found
back in Greta Gerwig is particularly
special that's what I love about
Hollywood is when you do get those
moments where it's real connections and
people are telling their real stories I
gotta admit I wanted a best directing
nomination for Greta - I don't how can
we not she's an amazing filmmaker and
and she I know is thrilled and I am
thrilled that that she's recognized for
her incredible adaptation as well as the
movie and the acting in the film so
that's it's beautiful but here's what we
know the more opportunity women have and
the more diversity we have both in front
of the camera and behind the camera the
more opportunities there will be to
celebrate and to celebrate female
visionaries and filmmakers and producers
but we are here little women as one of
our nominees with one producer as our as
our producer of Little Women Amy Pascal
who's so incredible so it's quite lovely
and then four big little lies
it's my buddies recently although our my
producers so it's you know it's it's
exciting to celebrate I got to see a lot
of those opportunities for women were
provided by recent nicole and big little
lies and of course everyone is dying to
know if a season 3 is happening what can
you tell us but you would be down find
out well I will not not be rich was my
favorite meme of 29 I I mean she
requires it and I love her so much so
I'm thrilled for her that she's a meme
because she would really appreciate it
and I could never say no not so much we
can never say no to you guys thank you
[Music]